avec nous tout de suite des brillants
sainte marie qui est le candidat dans
joliette pour le bloc québécois bonsoir
bonsoir à vous messieurs sainte marie un
cadre donc sur trois ans pourquoi
seulement trois ans les libéraux les
conservateurs ont présenté cinq ans le
directeur parlementaire travaille sur
cinq ans pourquoi juste trois ans de
sainte-marie avec la conjoncture qui
était incertaine tout change rapidement
on se souvient le dans la dernière année
et demie les mises à jour de budgétaire
du gouvernement changer de six mois en
six mois donc on s'est dit on va se
concentrer sur trois ans pour donner une
appréciation
d'un donjon un ordre une échelle de
temps qui devrait
plus plus plus courte pour avoir des
démarches
meilleurs chiffres mais moins de vision
en même temps parce que ya beaucoup de
dépenses vous êtes très dépensier 139
milliards de dollars sur trois ans 80 2
milliards de nouveaux revenus est-ce que
ce que vous proposez c'est dans les
faits une forme d'un déficit structurel
à long terme à ottawa ben je déficit
structurel
actuellement il existe puis à québec
puis pour les provinces parce que les
deux tiers des nouvelles dépenses qu'on
demande qu'on propose c'est un
financement adéquat du système de santé
on demande à ottawa de faire sa part
c'est-à-dire financer un peu plus le
tiers le fameux 35% qui demandait par
québec qui est demandé par les provinces
et qui est calculée par le directeur
parlementaire du budget justement donc
35 monter soit 35 % pour la santé et à
bien une augmentation de 6 % par année
c'est les deux tiers des dépenses non
dire que vous ne vous préoccupez pas de
financer ce transfert pour le
gouvernement fédéral dans votre cadre
financier aujourd'hui
je tiens à dire que
le cadre financier des conservateurs
mais ni les libéraux ni les les néo
démocrates ni les conservateurs jusqu'à
maintenant alors deux de retour à court
terme le sport on s'est concentré sur un
horizon de 3 à qui on dit un coup de
barre à donner
c'est de l'argent qui est actuellement
dépassé par québec les provinces les
deux tiers à santé ce qu'on veut si une
nouvelle répartition donc c'est le
signal qu'on a à voir qui est très
important il ya possible de retour à l
équilibre dans ce que vous présentez le
plus loin que vous allez donc c'est dans
trois ans effectivement ça nous amène un
déficit dans trois ans à 53 milliards de
dollars 53 milliards de déficit encore
dans trois ans est ce que votre plan est
vraiment viable pour le canada pour les
finances publiques mais je pense que
comme je vous disais là on a comme vous
l'avez dit aussi on accusa source de
nouveaux revenus on a des dépenses comme
votre collègue le disait il la santé il
ya le pouvoir d'achat des aînés c'est
des besoins qui sont nécessaires on
demande à ottawa et on suggère de donner
de donner un grand coup de barre pour
cela le pouvoir de ceux des années on le
sait la les baby boomers vont partir à
la retraite de plus en plus hélas ces
mesures leur augmenté de 110 dollars le
passion de sécurité de vieillesse par
mois pour avoir un espèce de rattrapage
étant donné que la hausse soit pas été
fait dans les dernières décennies
ça permet de stabiliser les la demande
un peu une partie de la demande agrégée
vie à la consommation pour préserver
leur pouvoir d'achat quand je compare à
l'international le taux de remplacement
ouais des revenus à la retraite au
canada il ya au québec le ior il ya 1
grâce à trois pages à faire donc des
mesures structurelles ici important puis
d'équité et qui coûte cher quand même je
veux dire oui c'est de liquider ça coûte
un certain prix c'est la même chose pour
les transferts en santé c'est peut-être
nécessaire mais ce qui serait pas
nécessaire d'avoir une vision plus long
terme sur les revenus par exemple vous
dit on va taxer davantage les riches on
va aller chercher de l'argent en taxant
avec un impôt ponctuel de troyes et de
zinc % sur les actifs des plus riches
mais ponctuel temporaire autrement dit
les revenus que vous identifier
s'évapore après quelques années oui mais
en même temps si on est capable d'avoir
une relance importants ce qu'il faut on
vient de passer à travers une crise
sanitaire on est encore dedans que des
répercussions économiques majeures ce
qu'on a appris le d'allier les dernières
décennies la théorie économique c'est
que le moindre des maux
c'est de stimuler la croissance
économique pour passer à travers donc
c'est on continue là dedans on veut qu'à
une relance verte pour l'impôt pour les
grandes fortunes ou les très grandes
entreprises se dire ok ces personnes là
ces grandes fortunes de ces grandes
entreprises là ont réalisé des profits
ou des bulles d'actifs augmenté de façon
extraordinaire pendant la pandémie ça se
sera enrichie donc on dit une fois étant
donné que s'il ya eu un gros effort de
guerre on va demander un effort de gars
justement une fois prélevées une portion
de cette augmentation là donc oui c'est
un grand coup de barre et tout ça c'est
pour après a su nous mettre sur des
rails va la croissance économique après
c'est plus facile d'équilibrer le budget
mais évidemment bras le l'exercice qu'on
fait on n'est pas là vous proposez une
péréquation verte de nouveau on vous
avait déjà entendu parler de ça mais
payées par les pollueurs autrement dit
la péréquation qui vient de nos impôts
que nous payons gouvernement fédéral et
gouvernement fédéral fait de la
péréquation serait remplacée par de la
péréquation qui vient des pollueurs
est-ce qu'on viendrait pas ébranler un
programme qui est essentiel aux
provinces particulièrement au québec car
quand on regarde les détails du
programme la péréquation elle est
maintenue toutefois le prix est en
partie remplacé en partie ou totalement
par notre proposition de péréquation
vert ici l'idée c'est de mettre les
provinces en concurrence les unes avec
les autres là l'heure actuelle on paye
la taxe carbone et le fonds est
retournée et reste dans la province et
le noir dybex au calcul c'est quoi la
moyenne d'émission est-ce qu'on est
est-ce qu'on fait mieux que la moyenne
ou pertes la moyenne et l'oeil un
programme de redistribution pour
encourager à sortir de la pollution
justement pour prendre le virage est
allié avec ça on a aussi développé
dévoilé aujourd'hui le notre programme
de finance verte parfait alors on garde
tout ça on se retrouve au débat
économique du 14 septembre merci
beaucoup mucem paris mais cette fois
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i hier d